[Music]
so ladies yes all you have all done
waitressing yes yes yes I mean I was a
cocktail waitress restaurant live
everyone needs to work in the service
industry I see with two years yeah so
you can learn how to [ __ ] be nice
what about just if you want to be nice
to people anyway and then you don't have
to work in services you don't live the
life and you're really know I work
customer service does that yes people
sometimes just don't know like well
there's empty tables over there how come
I can't sit this we don't have a [ __ ]
waitress there dude you complain about
not getting served yeah because either
waitress or our kitchen is that capacity
that's why you can't sit down Steve
always does this yeah but guess why
that's cuz my ninja can't about the
restaurant it was like you don't have a
person in a sec should I know it this is
what you need just like the bench I'm
not trying to be [ __ ] technical yeah
we said that bogey Taylor what do you
[ __ ] only it would make you only with
Nicky I don't [ __ ] to the people nice
to people it builds good character man
it's really you know why cuz my dad was
such an [ __ ] people growing up that I
went the other way I'll be overly nice
to people instead good so have you guys
ever been sexually harassed oh yeah yeah
I mean that's just everyone regardless
if you've been a waitress literally
never been sexually harassed before this
before like are you worked at worse I've
literally never been sexually harassed
before that's amazing like it might also
just be my perspective like I offended
by your body without your consent
if I did I didn't notice uh to me is
that's not even like sexual harassment
is just like unwanted
like catcalling yeah I guess I just want
to narrow down type one sexual assault
if they put a hand on you then that's
assault now and you know what it's
[ __ ] up
I've gotten cat calls from grown men
since I was nine years old we do see
those little [ __ ] disgust girls his
phone where were you I was just walking
home from school I had my backpack on
nabis so excellent tactical rings I
remember being seven years old and I was
gonna go
restore and there was this guy going
like like this old man and I'm like I
remember I think who I want to beat that
man oh I remember thinking like what
like why is this man doing this to me
and then like that kept happening over
and over again in public all these
grown-ass men and I was this tiny little
girl not even having my period yet and
like all these men are always like
you're just raised to feel like that
like something must be wrong with you if
you're not accepting that yeah you know
you always have a little self-esteem
because I got none cuz for me that's
just a tension I'm like some guys and
they do that [ __ ] I check that [ __ ] not
even just like young girls like women
women my thing is like it's like you
ever been driving with somebody like
we're homies and you see a chicken look
why you'll do all of that you're not
gonna turn around you almost killed us
where's the chick like that Nikki yeah
and we can be safely you don't have to
do like all of this rubberneck and [ __ ]
like I just don't like that so that's
again like another week I will go to
clubs I hate seeing guys so invasive I
think I post her story about this too it
was like maybe like a month or two ago I
was leaving my car walking home and I
turned the corner and this is a very
public street like and this guy was just
straight-up just jerking off yeah but he
was jerking off before I got there so
like it wasn't even for me like here
offended you're like hey wait to like
I'm in the picture your [ __ ]
peripherals and you're already late did
you know I was coming or something like
at least like you know he was about to
come
and I crossed the street because
obviously I wanted to get away from him
and I was like did he [ __ ] finish
that's why you've never been sexually
harassed so the reason why I've brought
up waitressing and sexual harassment
assault is because this waitress from
Cape Town in South Africa she shared a
video of this male model that was
grabbing her ass how she was working so
I'm gonna show you guys the surveillance
footage oh well first of all this is
what she looks like her name is Sarah
Sarah pretty cute she likes the actress
what's the main this is the male model
okay okay and this is Charles Manson
inspired and then he tries to like laugh
it off but then he continues to harass
her to the point where the friends had
to step in and tell him they're like
dude back off like back off of her I'm
just trying to see if he was drinking -
oh it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
does not matter it doesn't matter but
I'm saying that's ballsy Bravo to the
friends yeah [ __ ] exactly so then she
ends up um she ends up writing in her
caption she says this so on Friday night
I was at work I am currently a waitress
and I happened to be serving this man
rain rain dupe red wait how'd she find a
pen oh that's a good question I don't
know her the video says it all leaving
me with little to add you are exposed
caught in the act it breaks my heart
every I've watched it over and over
again feeling more like trash each time
men in South Africa this happens on a
regular basis what are you going to do
about it if you're seeing your mates do
this called them out don't wait for them
to get physical with women to call them
out men of South Africa stop touching us
inappropriately to rain do Prez friends
I thank you for stopping your friend
when he continued to insult and
humiliate me after touching me
inappropriately I only hope that more
can be done next time so then he ends up
responding on his social
Media on Instagram he says dear Sarah
and those affected by my behavior I
would like to take this opportunity to
express my sincerest apologies for my
actions the other night I am ashamed of
how I acted and can only imagine how
that made Sarah feel it was a bad it was
a moment of bad character under the
influence of alcohol and I truly did not
mean to belittle her or make her feel
violated I am NOT here to make excuses
but to explain my actions and to
publicly apologize I hope that Sarah can
find it in her heart to forgive me and
realize that everyone makes mistakes may
this be an example to all who have
watched this video that we should treat
each other with respect
she needs to realize that everyone makes
mistakes poorly worded explain but not
make excuses like let me defend myself
not mix yes and of course he didn't mean
to belittle her that's the problem he
didn't even see her as a person he
wasn't thinking about her feelings that
I'll see is it evening yeah you were
just like this is mine for the taking
yeah especially with that like she needs
to realize part where it's like
obviously really cocky you know I will
say though okay this might have to get
cut out of the video if it seems like
what do you have to say um I feel like
one of the things that she liked I wish
that was done a little differently and
that is that the other men the friends
stepped up to defend her and so I almost
wished it when it was phrased it was
like not men of South Africa because
that attacks everyone but if it's like
creepy dudes they can't keep their hands
themselves it gets other men to like
support and be like well she's not
talking to me [ __ ] that guy it's
separating even by grouping them all it
just makes everyone feel like they're
personally attacked I totally agree with
that cuz out as I was reading it the
first time I'm like just reword it a
little yeah but I mean and it's like it
like I know that her intent was to you
know bring action and like I think that
you not only just have to have the
support of women but you need the
support of men to encourage it followed
it up to she said is that guys in South
Africa if you see your mate doing yeah
yeah yeah yeah she's just so go back
with it and I know that I hope that most
people will see that that wasn't her
intent to group them all together
happens a lot like a woman has a great
intention of trying to make some kind of
change but instead everyone feels
grouped together and they get kind of
attacked like they'll stop writing
halfway and then just fixate on that so
whenever I post like the creepy [ __ ]
messages that I get I specifically say
creepy men should get their dicks kicked
in yeah yep but then there's always
someone that says not all men someone
that's taking it personally yeah perhaps
maybe their heads they are guilty maybe
they are the creepy man they feel
attacked but any other normal guy
reading that would say oh she said
immediate and the overall lesson is
great right like for guys like you know
when you see that [ __ ] going down like
what you hear said like checking your
dudes around you and be like that's not
cool so that they don't feel comfortable
to do it oh dude
if a guy check this random was I came in
that wasn't cool I'm like you I'm gonna
but not you know yeah I'm gonna be like
you but they're gonna [ __ ] you there are
white knight types that are almost
equally as bad we're like we get off on
like being like I know what she wants
treated like that's bad why are you
[ __ ] me now wait why aren't you
[ __ ] you such a [ __ ] [ __ ] one
piece of intention I'd say you silk
sheets for free from Amazon wishlist I
just send me nudes you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] I protected you
from the bad that's why I'm tired of
giving such free [ __ ] from Amazon
wishlist man that's so ridiculous that
people would do that what the what the
contingency of you returning something
to that I didn't know the ones that
[ __ ] about like how girls don't like
nice guys and it's like or not the nice
guy
got you
oh then they spent $44 on you and dinner
true you [ __ ] they put nice collar they
wore a fedora at least at least the
[ __ ] douchebag guys you see them
coming these guys 13 on this during the
tallgrass yeah those are worse yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]